stephen hawking ist nicht nur einer der
renommiertesten wissenschaftler weltweit
gewesen er war auch ein großer visionär
und hat auch durchaus kontroverse thesen
vertreten und er hat auch verrückte
experimente gemacht eines davon betrifft
zeitreisen
denn hawking chance zumindest die
möglichkeit nicht aus dass es zeit
reisen geben können was ist also mit
hawkings zeit reisen auf sich hat jetzt
in unserer kleinen serie in loser folge
in memoriam stephen hawking klicks im
science fiction herzlich willkommen
stephen hawking ist sich sicher in der
zukunft werden wir in die zukunft reisen
können und das ist eigentlich auch
nichts besonderes wenn man sich mit der
speziellen relativitätstheorie
beschäftigt da legt sich immer mit
derselben geschwindigkeit fortbewegt ja
ich weiß in verschiedenen medien ist das
anders was aber mit der interaktion der
photonen also der lichtteilchen mit den
teilchen dort zu tun hat also eine pause
darstellt also liegt hat eine
unabänderliche geschwindigkeit 299.000
792 458 meter pro sekunde das sind so
rund eine milliarde kilometer pro stunde
da die lichtgeschwindigkeit aber
unabänderlich ist muss sich alles darum
verändern raum und zeit werden gekrümmt
bei hohen geschwindigkeiten führt das zu
einem langsameren verlauf der zeit das
heißt im umkehrschluss außerhalb zum
beispiel eines raumschiffes verläuft die
zeit viel schneller
das kann zb heißen dass an bord eines
schnell fliegenden raumschiffes ein jahr
vergeht während auf der erde zehn jahre
vergehen auf diese weise könnte ich in
die zukunft reisen aber geht es auch
zurück es gibt ja in der quantenphysik
modelle die reisen in die vergangenheit
ermöglichen allerdings nur dort es geht
um schwarze löcher die die raumzeit so
stark krümmen dass er am ende auf sich
zurück gekrümmt sind doch es gibt ein
problem ein wichtiges prinzip der physik
ursache und wirkung würde damit auf den
kopf gestellt werden denn die ursache
liegt demnach immer in der vergangenheit
und die wirkung in der zukunft deshalb
wagte hawking ein spannendes experiment
er veranstaltete eine party schickte die
einladung aber erst danach auf
besonderes haltbaren papier ab dass also
jahrtausende überdauern würde
nachfahren von uns hätten die einladung
eigentlich finden müssen
doch auf der party erschien kein
einziger gast zumindest in diesem
experiment konnte also ursache
verschicken der einladung in der zukunft
und wirkung partygäste in der
vergangenheit nicht umkehren es spricht
also einiges dafür dass es zeitreisen in
die vergangenheit nicht gibt wir hätten
solche zeitreisende schon längst auf
spiele müssen aber es gibt ja eine
quelle die viel effizienter in der lage
ist zeitreisender aufzuspüren das
internet und da hat sich ein
forschungsteam daran gemacht dass nach
zeitreisenden zu durchsuchen sie
forschen einfach auf twitter nach ob es
jeweils einen einzigen tweet gibt der
das erscheinen des kometen izone 2012
heraus sagt oder die wahl von hornberg
gollnow zum papst franziskus das
ergebnis auf ganz twitter gibt es keinen
einzigen tweet der einst dieser beiden
ereignisse voraus sagte sieht also
schwer danach aus als das
höchstwahrscheinlich zeitreisen in die
vergangenheit nie möglich sein
es scheint also so dass es
wahrscheinlich im bereich der
quantenphysik bewegung in der
umgekehrten zeit richtung geben könnte
aber für uns menschen das nie realität
wird auf die neuesten erkenntnisse sind
dazu bin ich gespannt wenn ihr als
erstes neues zum thema zeitreisen und zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
endet meine telefonnummer wards
erpressen
direkter link dann erfahrt ihr von mir
vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über
mich in der redaktion von kling zum
mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen
oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen und
mitbestimmen was ihr bei pixum passiert
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das
aber mit der genau glocke vergessen
und hier geht es weiter damit dafür auch
draufklicken stephen hawking ist tot das
war ja eine wirklich sehr sehr traurige
meldung und da gibt es alles zum thema
ansonsten bis dahin bleibt dran